timo sheen ist in seiner ghetto gang der
anführer seinen weg in die kriminelle
karriere vorprogrammiert
was los daran führer leute seid ihr
heute morgen mit dem gefühl aufgewacht
mensch wir leben hier in deutschland
eigentlich schon einem schönen land
unser gesundheitssystem ist ob wir haben
die aktuelle problematik wirklich
einmalig gehandelt es gibt kaum ein land
auf der welt war es die aktuelle
problematik so gute welt in deutschland
unsere wirtschaft geht relativ gut und
unserer jugend gehört die zukunft wenn
er diese frage mit ja beantwortet habe
dann kann ich euch beruhigen das werdet
ihr gleich nicht mehr denken denn die
wir uns heute eine neue folge von die
strengsten eltern der welt reinziehen
ich habe den richtigen riecher für euch
rausgesucht nehmen wir jetzt mal
reinschauen werden das video heißt
zugekauft und gewaltbereit timucin
kennen keine angst und wir sagen jetzt
berlin-steglitz hier wächst der 15
jährige timo gene auf waffen drogen und
alkohol sind für den deutsch türken das
größte da können wir eigentlich direkt
wieder lassen jetzt eigentlich schon
wieder viel zu viele vergehen um sie
ausschließen zu können
wie viele sekunden hatte jetzt das waren
zehn sekunden gerade heute 10
okay wer thema aufgeflext mit einer
softair-pistole das ist das ist gangster
das ist gangster die schießt bestimmt zu
feste das mit ein bisschen glück die
kugel in einem apfel stecken bleibt er
hat mit seiner gang posiert und hat uns
als zuschauer wirklich in
eindrucksvoller art und weise gezeigt
dass sie die chefs am block sind und er
ist die kamera zugelaufen hat nach der
kamera gehauen und gesagt dass er mit
der mutter der kamera geschlechtsverkehr
praktiziert sehr gute gene ist in seiner
ghetto gängen daran führer um seinen weg
in die kriminelle karriere ging es
weiter - er ist der anführer aller
anderen so drei köpfe größer der wiesn
geht euch mal dieses bild der ist könnte
sein großer bruder sein wenn ersten zehn
ist der große bruder ist 20 dsk seine
software ziehen
stimmt
alkoholexzesse bis zum umfallen sind das
freizeitvergnügen der kette gang auch
kiffen gehört seit jahren zum alltag
oh gott oh gott okay okay sagt nicht ich
kann es ich kann es euch nur sagen leute
lasst bloß die finger davon wenn ihr
noch jung sei teuer gehirn nicht
vollständig entwickelt ist ich finde vor
dem 19 geburtstag oder so was was auch
mal die grenzen sollte man generell die
finger von lassen und da habe ich noch
nicht darüber gesprochen dass er nicht
mal annähernd 19 ist erst 15 macht es
angeblich schon seit jahren
das heißt sein gehirn wird er
höchstwahrscheinlich ziemlich trost sein
in steglitz fühlt sich der junge
gangster unantastbar
bei den streiks in steglitz fühlt sich
der junge gangster unantastbar leute wie
kann man an diesem punkt ankommen dass
man sich mit 15 unantastbar fühlt mit 15
ok drei jahre bevor man legal zigaretten
kaufen darf oder irgendwie alkohol
kaufen darf oder irgendwann der drei
jahre bevor du erst ein vollwertiger
erwachsener nur auf dem papier ist noch
lange nicht im kopf die kann man sich in
diesem alter unantastbar für also jetzt
mal noch fand dann alle jammern da
draußen aber wenn man jung ist sollte
man sich auch gefälligst als kleiner
pisser fühlen so wie ich mich früher
auch als kleiner pisser gefühlt aber sie
klein war und nicht als don corleone
oder pablo escobar respekt vor nichts
und niemandem nach diesem motto lebt
nicht nur timo schien auch die 15
jährige monika aus berlin-marzahn hält
sich nur an ihre eigenen regeln
solange tasche da kommt ist ja alles
okay
1 kommentar auch ihr vom taschengeld
bosse also ich glaub mir leute nichts
ist mehr gangster als das taschengeld
von seinen eigenen eltern zu nehmen und
dann zu sagen dass man nach den eigenen
regeln lebt seit monaten ist ihr zuhause
die straße ok dann nimmst wird so und
taschengeld ist überhaupt los auch gut
auch gut wer die fünf weil die 517 nach
diesem motto lebt nicht nur timo schien
auch die 15 jährige monique aus
armes deutschland
armes deutschland muss man wirklich
sagen gebt mittfünfziger mit 15 auf der
straße ab
es geht wie kriege ich jetzt schon
wieder mitleid leute new york oder
willst ich komme da nicht ruhig kommen
dann nicht umher leute es ist immer
lustig im ersten moment so kleine pizza
sag ich jetzt mal die klappe aufmachen
und große sprüche toppen aber die tun
mir auch schon geistiger 15 und oft habe
ich es gar nicht verstanden heute hätte
es gar nicht verstanden auf der straße
zu leben also obdachlos zu sein ist
besser als in die schule zu gehen und zu
hause zu sein hat sie ganz so gesagt
naja 200 also ich meine leute wie los
kann man sein aber selbst immer so einen
teenager es will wissen wer job gemacht
seine eltern ist der stress macht wie
kann man denn vor sich selbst sagen ja
ich bin lieber auf der straße weil die
schule als langweilig ach ja und man
muss sagen auf der straße zu können dass
höchstwahrscheinlich nicht langweilig
jeden tag warten ihre eltern in der
marzahner plattenbausiedlung auf ein
lebenszeichen ihrer tochter doch die
lässt sich nur noch blicken wenn sie
geld oder klamotten braucht na ja das
ist wirklich set das ist einfach
wirklich geisteskrank sei man muss aber
auch dazu sagen ihre eltern sitzen
zuhause und warten auf ein zeichen ihrer
tochter und sie mehr kriegen scheinbar
kein zeichen von ihrer tochter ja so wie
es aussieht währenddessen komplett das
kamerateam von kabel 1 dreht mit der
tochter kabel eins hätte man da nicht
mal sagen wie ist eure tochter sie ist
bei uns so sie lebt noch sie ist hier
bei diesem apparat nicht aber leute man
muss aber auch sagen auch wenn ich
eigentlich immer mit für die emotional
das ist auch schon krass kitschig
gemacht jetzt film wieso die tasse der
beste papa der welt damit alle sie
naja ein bisschen stumpf mutter gabi und
vater mirco müssen hilflos zusehen wie
ihre geliebte tochter unaufhaltsam immer
tiefer abrutscht wie soll ich sehe
nämlich und dann kann es auch nicht zu
sehen
in front immerhin das immerhin dass
leute wenn ihr euer eigenes kind nicht
mehr seht weil es auf der straße erlebt
was vernünftigerweise auch die
entscheidung ist dies getroffen hat weil
wir alle wissen leute schule ist
langweilig und was ist besser als sich
in der schule für 45 stunden in der
woche fünfmal zu langweilen genau
komplett auf der straße zu verquicken
das ist deutlich besser
dabei haben die eltern monique immer ein
heiles familienleben geboten haben ihr
liebe und aufmerksamkeit geschenkt und
versucht ihr alle wünsche zu erfüllen
wie kann das sein wie kann das sagen ich
fand es immer wieder leute wenn ihr
schon ein paar videos von mir geschaut
hat auch die strengsten eltern der welt
normalerweise ist meine reaktion immer
ja ich die eltern haben da auch eine
teilschuld dran es kann nicht sein dass
so ein kind einfach so frei drehen aber
dicker packen was sagt ihr dazu
was haltet ihr davon so wird es jetzt
die lage schnell wird ist es ja immerhin
mal ein elternhaus wo beide eltern da
ist mir was ihr auch schon relativ
selten der fall ist bei die strengsten
eltern der welt und wirkt ja so als
hätten sie ihr kind mehr oder weniger
liebevoll auch großgezogen wie kann das
sein dass wir dann so frei dreht in
berlin steglitz haben oder leon und
seine freundin agatha den 15 jährigen
timo gene in ihre obhut genommen
die schwerkranke mutter kann sich seit
jahren nicht mehr um ihn kümmern
das ist genau das ist es nämlich genau
das was ich meine das ist so ein
familiendrama vom vater war bis dato
noch keine rede die mutter ist krank
kann sich nicht um ihn kümmern und dann
muss der große bruder einspringen das
ist so noch etwas wo ich sage okay da
sehe ich schon ein bisschen mehr so die
faktoren dafür dass so ein kind so
durchdreht weil es irgendwie die familie
nicht so ganz funktioniert aber was
machen das jetzt bei der anderen egal
reden wir nochmal über team und schien
wenn ich mir das vorstelle ich bin ja
auch der größere bruder in unserer
familie habe eine kleine schwester haben
kleinen oder alter wenn einer von denen
so viel zu durch drehen würde dich ja
ich weiß es nicht ich würde den im
schlimmsten fall durch den
wahrscheinlichen keller einsperren oder
so einfach freiheitsberaubung straight
begehen damit ihr einfach nicht so ein
mist macht einfach weil ich ihn liebe
wisst ihr was ich meine seite einem
don quijote nun bei seinem bruder der
25-jährige arbeit wird als türsteher und
führt bei seinem kleinen bruder zu hause
drogen und waffen kontrollen durch oh
mein gott das ist wirklich armes
deutschland
selbst das mal vorbestellt euch eure
familie vorstellt ich vor ihr habt einen
kleinen bruder wenn ja schon ein
bisschen älter seid oder macht er weiter
an meinem kopf ist mitte zwanzig bruder
ist 15 kommt nach hause und der kleine
pizza ich sage das aber es ist auch das
ist doch kinderalter wir sind kinder wie
sie verhalten sich so wie er wie
kriminelle erwachsene der kommt nach
hause und ist so ruft das du kontrollen
bei ihnen durchführen muss obwohl timo
gene die tür kontrolle zu hause kennt
hat er fast immer schreckschusspistolen
und schlagstöcke bei sich
ich muss bei dem in dem polier bei den
beiden jetzt hier bin ich ein bisschen
optimistischer weil der bruder wird
schon so als hätte einen guten einfluss
so denn der kommt zumindest halbwegs
klar so auf das ist ein zeichen von mir
also das sagt einfach keiner klar kommt
deswegen kann man sie auch keinen
festhalten alle drehen sich einfach
untereinander herum und drehen durch so
aber er ich glaube ich glaube er ist auf
dem richtigen weg so erkannt seinem
kleinen bruder helfen da vielleicht
hören auf den bruder hat man auch noch
eher als auf die eigenen eltern also da
sehe ich noch eine chance aber der
anderen den einfachen leuten wieder
schwer gefangen zwischen einerseits
sport gegenüber den absurden sachen sie
die machen und mitleid mit deren
lebenssituation die hat echt nicht so
nice das treibt man die kommentare was
ihr davon haltet und wenn ihr nicht
wollt das team und über euch vorbei
kommt und euch mal ausraubt mit einer
softair-pistole dann täglich
vorgestelltes wie abonniert hier um
einen kanal ich bin raus